hagamos más problemas sobre la ecuación
del gas ideal vamos a decir que tenemos
gas en un contenedor y la presión la
presión es igual
tres atmósferas tres atmósferas el
volumen del contenedor el volumen es
igual a
9 litros 9 litros litros ahora cuál
sería la presión si el volumen cambia de
9 litros a digamos 3 litros
3 litros entonces con lo que aprendimos
en el primer vídeo sobre la ecuación
podemos darnos cuenta de que en este
caso hay una temperatura constante
habíamos visto que al estudiar que hay
detrás de la ecuación del gas ideal
dijimos que si tenemos un cierto número
de partículas vamos a dejarlo
si tenemos un cierto número de
partículas con una energía cinética y
además aplican una presión al contenedor
a la parte interna del contenedor si lo
hacemos más pequeño más pequeño tenemos
el mismo número de partículas la misma
energía cinética pero chocan más con las
paredes por lo que cuando el volumen es
más pequeño cuando el volumen disminuye
la presión aumenta
veamos si podemos calcular el número
exacto
tomando la ecuación del gas ideal
presión por volumen es igual a n
t el número de partículas cambiará ahora
que el contenedor se ha encogido no
existe el mismo número de partículas el
contenedor es más pequeño entonces n s n
r es una constante y la temperatura
tampoco cambia así que la presión que
conocemos por el volumen será igual a n
rt y la presión a calcular por el
volumen déjenme escribir esto con p 1 b
1 p 2 igual al perdón esto no es la
presión
esto es volumen
de 2 y de 2 que es la presión que
buscamos bueno sabemos que de 1 por b 1
es igual
en rt y también sabemos que la
temperatura y el número de moles del gas
es constante así que p 2 x b 2 es igual
también a n rt como son igual a lo mismo
podemos decir que la presión por el
volumen mientras que la temperatura sea
constante sea la misma que uno por b 1
es igual a pedos por b 2 y que era p 1 b
1 nuestra presión inicial es de 3
atmósferas
tres atmósferas
atmósferas por 9 litros es igual a la
presión 2 por 3 litros si dividimos
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 3
obtenemos que los 3 y los litros se
cancelan
y nos quedan
nos quedan
nueve atmósferas
nueve atmósferas y esto tiene sentido
porque cuando disminuimos el volumen en
un tercio un tercio del volumen original
entonces la presión aumenta en un factor
de tres esto multiplica por tres y esto
por un tercio en general si la
temperatura se mantiene constante la
presión y el volumen presión por volumen
será una constante podemos llevar esto
mucho más lejos si tomamos que tve en
rtvv es igual a n rt las dos cosas que
sabemos que no cambian en la mayoría de
los ejercicios es el número de moléculas
y obviamente r que permanece constante
entonces si dividimos entre la
temperatura bebé entre t es igual a
enero y esto es igual a una constante
para cualquier sistema si no cambiamos
el número de moléculas dentro del
contenedor es una constante si cambiamos
la presión hace un momento empezamos con
que t 1 por b 1 y ahora entre alguna t 1
será igual a esta constante y si
cambiamos a alguna de ellas si buscamos
presión 2 por volumen 2 / temperatura 2
también son iguales está constante
entonces son iguales entre sí por
ejemplo digamos que empiezo con una
presión de una atmósfera
una atmósfera y tenemos un volumen de
vamos a cambiar las unidades aquí para
hacer las cosas diferentes dos metros
cúbicos y tenemos una temperatura de una
temperatura de 27 grados 27 grados
celsius y bueno está dada en celsius
pero recuerden que siempre hay que
convertir a kelvin es decir 27 grados
más 273 es igual a 300 300 grados kelvin
y digamos que la nueva temperatura la
nueva temperatura vamos a ver
la nueva presión es de dos atmósferas
dos atmósferas la presión aumentó y al
contenedor lo hacemos más pequeño de un
metro un metro cúbico
entonces el contenedor se redujo a la
mitad la presión aumentó el doble con lo
que podemos adivinar que si déjenme
hacer contenedor más pequeño
mejor la presión más grande
mejor la presión
subiré la presión a cinco atmósferas
cinco atmósferas y ahora ya podemos
calcular cuál es la temperatura 2
establecida la ecuación tenemos que 2
entre 300 atmósferas metro cúbico por
kelvin es igual a 5 sobre t 2 la nueva
temperatura entonces sería de tenemos
que 1500 es igual a dos porteros de 2 es
igual a 750 grados kelvin lo que tiene
sentido verdad porque aumentamos tanto
la presión y disminuimos el volumen al
mismo tiempo por lo que la temperatura
tenía que subir o visto de otra manera
tal vez como aumentamos la temperatura
por eso la presión subió especialmente
porque disminuimos el volumen tenemos
que pensar en que esta presión aumentó
tanto hasta cinco atmósferas porque en
cogimos el volumen en un factor de 1
lo que duplica la presión por eso eran
las dos atmósferas y luego hicimos que
la temperatura fuera mucho más alta lo
cual también se refleja en el contenedor
porque la temperatura de 750 kelvin es
más del doble de la temperatura inicial
y eso nos lleva a las cinco atmósferas
ahora otra cosa sobre la que tal vez
quieren saber es sobre qué pasa con las
condiciones normales de presión y
temperatura
déjenme quitar todo esto
quitaré todo lo que ya no necesitamos
condiciones normales de presión y
temperatura lo estoy mencionando porque
aún las condiciones normales de presión
y temperatura también conocidas como
cnpt desafortunadamente para el mundo a
veces no se tiene muy claro cuáles son
esas condiciones pero busqué en
wikipedia y lo más común para las
pruebas a condiciones normales es
utilizar una temperatura de cero grados
celsius
es decir 273 grados kelvin y la presión
es de una atmósfera aquí en wikipedia
nos dicen que es de 101 punto 325
kilopascales o poco más de 101.000
pascal es donde el pascal es un newton
por metro cuadrado
todo esto de las unidades es un poco
difícil de entender pero vamos a suponer
que todo esto son diferentes condiciones
normales basadas en estudios de
diferentes instituciones que se dedican
a esto pero nosotros tomemos esto como
la definición de las condiciones
normales de presión y temperatura
suponemos que la temperatura es igual a
cero grados celsius que es igual a 273
grados kelvin y la presión suponemos que
es de una atmósfera que es igual a 101
punto 325 kilopascales entonces me
preguntáis si tenemos un gas un gas
ideal a condiciones normales de
temperatura y presión cuantos moles hay
de ese gas en un litro
mejor lo pondré de otra manera cuántos
litros se necesitan para un mol
n es igual a un mol y quiero saber cuál
es el volumen entonces si tengo un molde
el gas
eso es 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23 moléculas de
un gas que está a una atmósfera y 273
grados kelvin cuál es el volumen de ese
gas aplicamos la ecuación bebé es igual
nr t donde presión es igual a una
atmósfera una atmósfera por el volumen
que no lo conocemos lo vamos a poner en
morado y esto es igual a un mol
un molde el gas por el por la
temperatura que es igual a 273 grados
kelvin esto está en kelvin atmósfera y
el volumen lo queremos en litros
entonces cuál es la constante r que
usaremos vamos a ver si trabajamos con
atmósferas y queremos el volumen en
litros y por supuesto tenemos mol y
kelvin usamos este valor este uno se
cancela con este así el volumen es igual
a punto 0 82 por 273 grados kelvin y eso
es
punto 0 0 82 por 273 es igual a 22.4
volumen es igual a 22.4 litros
entonces si tengo un gas o ideal claro
no todos los gases se comportan
idealmente pero en un caso ideal a
condiciones normales es decir a cero
grados celsius o también 273 grados
kelvin un molde ese gas a condiciones
normales de presión y de temperatura
requiere exactamente 22.4 litros y si
quieren saber a cuántos metros cúbicos
equivale eso bueno 22.4 litros por
cuántos metros cúbicos hay en un litro
por cada metro cúbico hay mil litros
parecen muchos pero es verdad imaginen
que tan grande es un metro cúbico esto
es igual es igual a punto cero 224
metros cúbicos
en un molde a una atmósfera y cero
grados celsius
es bueno saber todo esto porque por
ejemplo si tienen dos moles a las
condiciones normales de presión y
temperatura cuántos litros se necesitan
buen o un mal necesita esta cantidad y
en dos moles a condiciones normales
necesitan el doble de esto porque al
tomar la ecuación de pv
la nrc sólo estamos duplicando el valor
de n todo lo demás se mantiene constante
así que si duplicamos el número de moles
se duplique el volumen o con número de
moles tendrás el volumen que se necesita
un gasto ideal a condiciones normales de
presión y temperatura una atmósfera y
273 grados kelvin requiere un volumen de
22.4 litros